liebe mitbürger senders darinnen wertes
gesocks volk von simulanten und
elektrosmog hypochondern er sei es das
allerletzte dass man sich als präsident
nur wünschen kann euch geht's einfach zu
gut ich kann ein blödes gejammer nicht
mehr hören
ich habe im alter eine versorgungslücke
zwischen den ohren und ich erst im alter
was mache ich mit meinem geld in der
niedrigzinsphase
wie wär's denn mit ausgeben schon mal
gehört wird meine oma immer gesagt der
sack hat kein regal auf einiges runde
tue beim fressen für mich an begann es
wasser und glutenfreien kürbisfest
gefällig den müll den sich die
agrarindustrie für euch ausgedacht hat
verwöhnte branche
kein wunder bei unserem kaputten
bildungssystem die steckdosen und
jalousien in diesem land sind
mittlerweile intelligenter als die
abiturienten und liebe senioren hört
endlich auf euer leben durch das tragen
von fahrradhelmen sinnlos zu verlängern
früher hat es der deutsche maurer noch
tot gesoffen wird mit 65 passend vom
gerüst gefallen
auf diesem fundament oder unser
rentensystem errichtet eines der besten
der welt
heute ist unsere medizinische versorgung
viel zu gut jeden tag fahren deutsche
rentner nach polen und lassen sich 400
eine neue hüfte an den arsch nagelt da
werden weil es in regionen des körpers
verlegt in denen noch nie eine arterie
gewesen ist trotzdem wird nur um
gemeckert und die da oben sind an allem
schuld macht doch selber mal was deshalb
nennt man euch staatsbürger und nicht
biomasse mit internetanschluss beteiligt
euch an der demokratischen
willensbildung tretet meinetwegen sogar
in die fdp ein
alles besser als grund vor einer brüllt
und wenn ihr das nicht kapiert mache ich
hier in bemühen die tür von innen zu
film einen ehrensold und guckt den
vierten teil von bibi und tina zu ende
[Applaus]